[Musique]
il ya les bains de boue les barry de
cèdre la thérapie à lauzon hélicoptère
de dijon et chenôve attach de
l'équipement n'a pas vraiment changé je
dors les édifices non plus quoique
certains ont été restaurés
l'architecturé d'une autre époque
quand les travailleurs de l'ex urss
venait ici pour se repose
nous sommes à qui cela va dans la région
du caucase comme on l'appelle ici la
ville des sanatoriums de russie dans les
couloirs de ces institutions
chaque pièce est numérotée les clients
se promènent avec leur fiche de
traitement pour prouver la bonne ils ont
l'air d'être en vacances ou encore aux
sports
mais la plupart sont ici pour récupérer
d'une infection qui les a complètement
abattu d'escrocs grands escrocs ou parce
qu une homologue il le lot c'est elle
qui a développé le programme posco vide
en partenariat avec le ministère de la
santé
elle nous a ouvert les portes de ses
champs où chacun a ses blessures de
guerre
kolda natalia la gorge nouée quand elle
explique que 50% de ses poumons ont été
endommagées par la coved
elle reçoit aujourd'hui des injections
d'ozon d'un traitement alternatif pour
stimuler la circulation
elle en aura aussi à la tête pour
contrer la perte de cheveux
c'est un des nombreux et mystérieuse
effets secondaires de la coved qui ont
été observés chez les patients
opi paul et d'étreintes les symptômes
varient et se manifeste sous plusieurs
formes et bridge à enstone moc est une
fête une l'art consommé 1 de presse
son prochain patient est passé par toute
la gamme
et il y en est à sa deuxième visite au
sanatorium depuis le printemps
oui pascal côté est un canadien
il a crevé de la presque tué cet hiver
en russie quand il est venu voir sa
femme qui est sur le point d'immigrer au
canada
lorsque j ai pu faire le test de kobe
pour prendre l'avion
on m'annonce que j'ai le coc vide en une
semaine ça conditions se détériorent
il est admis à l'hôpital à oufa puis aux
soins intensifs il fallait qu'il agisse
rapidement sinon il va perdre nippon
était affecté plus de 80% le réflexe ne
peut même plus à respirer
pascal se considère chanceux d'être en
vie il est sorti de l'hôpital avec une
machine à oxygène portative incapable de
fonctionner ni même de marché le risque
d'embolie aux poumons l'empêchent de
prendre l'avion pour ses médecins le
sanatorium est incontournable c'est très
simple attention les visions de
rationnel de sanatorium que nous on ne
rompt pas vos cadeaux mais si on
continue à l'excuser locaux avaient de
fait en sorte de ghetto les spécialistes
au niveau des monnaies
ces systèmes internes ici donc non plus
facilement un programme et on accepte
presque scellé sans changement
il est aujourd'hui un habitué de ces
cures régimentaire à la soviétique qui
dure d'une à trois semaines où l'horaire
et planifie au quart de tour et 700 par
jour on est assez des journées intenses
tout le monde mange en même temps qu'à
trois par jour au menu les protéines
surtout essentiel pour reconstruire le
système immunitaire
maria melnikova mans mais ne goûte
absolument rien depuis qu elle a eu
l'accord et 19 en février elle a aussi
perdu l'odorat
nous l'avons revu plus tard avec pascal
dans une cave de sel un traitement
prescrit pour les aider à restaurer
leurs fonctions respiratoires
elle dit que les quintes de toux sont
encore fréquentes et elle s'y souffle
pour un rien pascal est passé par la luz
on ça confirme plus que nos passe au
travers et on se dit mon époque où que
l'on n'est pas seul dans cette situation
n'existe pour le moment aucun traitement
miracle aux études que je crois un peu
la circulaire symboliquement dans un
film on sent bon le corps mais si les
sanatoriums de kiss la botte et ses
environs sont devenus la mecque des
soins post co vide c'est parce que la
région était déjà bien avant la pandémie
une destination pour le tourisme médical
et les maladies pulmonaires avec l'air
frais de ses montagnes et ses bains
thérapeutiques
j'étais à 0 à certains de plage devient
sentir à neuf aujourd'hui
l'adie mire est lui aussi rescapé du
coran navire s'il ne veut rien laisser
oiseaux j'espère que ce soit contre les
russes viennent aujourd'hui de partout
pour se refaire une simple
ont profité de la célèbre eau minérale
denard than qui fait partie de tous les
programmes de réadaptation chaque
sanatorium enserre religieusement matin
et soir pour combattre la fatigue
chronique
un des symptômes les plus persistants de
la coved dit la docteure yekaterina
ovtchinnikova le sanatorium où elle
pratique accueillait autrefois les
travailleurs de la mine qui avaient des
problèmes respiratoires
aujourd'hui un client sur trois se remet
du corps un navire
on travaille avec les traditions de la
médecine soviétique qui était célèbre
dans le monde entier de la docteure mais
on l'a enrichie avec des nouvelles
élites c'est le côté que le paradoxe je
pense d'eux mais la russie un peu de
prévention pour faire face à la cause il
dit pascal mais une panoplie de soins
pour combattre les effets à long terme
dans le post crevé on commence à se
réveiller au canada pour nous et il
faudrait peut-être avoir une vision
peut-être là bas alors qu'ici à pau les
cloisons qu'on retrouve chez nous donc
cette vision lorsque tous les services
sous un même toit et s'est fait
incroyable qu'on peut voir la même
journée un urologue et moins jeunes
élèves de log et en heure c'est fait et
pourquoi chers d'ailleurs la plupart des
patients ont été envoyés ici aux frais
de leur employeur pascal qui est un
avocat travail à distance se consacre à
la marche au quotidien sauf qu'il lui
reste du chemin à faire même si mois
après la copie des réseaux vous nommant
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il peut
rentrer au canada
et quelle aventure à deux semaines en
russie qui s'est prolongé de façon pour
moi le plus importante que je l'avais
imaginé au début oui mais six mois
enfant j'ai dit le pirée mais il
un voyage dans le temps dans ces vieux
établissements russes vous même la danse
s'invite alors elle est où en pleine
pandémie
la nostalgie côtoie la résilience
[Musique]